bonsoir
aider l'Ukraine Emmanuel Macron retour à
la dure réalité de 2022 un échange qui
devait porter sur la guerre en Ukraine a
vite déborder sur la relation de Marine
Le Pen avec ses créanciers russes ce que
vous dépendez du pouvoir russe et que
vous dépendez de Monsieur Poutine parce
que quelques mois après avoir dit cela
Madame Le Pen vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
la First shake Russian Bank proche du
pouvoir je suis une femme absolument et
totalement libre et que je défends parce
que je suis une patriote et que je l'ai
démontré toute ma vie vous avez proposé
la plus grosse subvention aux
hydrocarbures de contre les changements
climatiques Emmanuel Macron avait
l'occasion d'attaquer sa rivale il l'a
fait vous êtes climato-sceptique Marine
Le Pen avait prévu le coup sa réponse
était prête mais vous vous êtes un peu
climatohypocrite
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être pour ça que
les gens ne croient pas à votre volonté
de régler tous ces problèmes-là la
réforme des retraites sujets importants
de cette campagne a fait l'objet des
changes très vif Emmanuel Macron veut
faire passer l'âge admissible de 62 à 65
ans alors que Marine Le Pen soit au
contraire qu'on ramène le seuil à 60 ans
la retraite à 65 ans c'est une injustice
absolument
insupportable monsieur Macron ces
progrès faut pouvoir les financer et
avant même ces progrès notre régime est
déséquilibré je suis pour l'interdiction
du voile dans l'espace public vous allez
créer la guerre civile si vous faites ça
je vous le dis en toute sincérité il
fallait s'y attendre c'est la question
du port du voile qui a créé les plus
forts moments de tension dans ce débat
que la France patrie des Lumières de
l'universel serait le premier pays au
monde à interdire les signes religieux
dans l'espace public le débat entre les
deux aspirants au poste de président de
la France a mis en évidence le caractère
irréconciliable de leur vision du monde
à l'image de la division du pays entre
la France des villes et la France des
régions et des campagnes